i was in russia last year with my dad  because  he was trying to get off he was on a  number of medications that were  that were really treating his ssri  withdrawal  and he was he had academia from these  medications  and he couldn't get treatment in north  america because they kept adding on more  medications and when we got to russia  they did mris and they looked at his  brain and they said  oh he has brain changes it's probably  from the  you know 15 years of ssri use and  and i was there thinking you can see  brain changes  from ssri use that cannot be good  and it's not something i'd ever heard in  north america that  that there are changes you can see on  mris  based on psychotropic drug usage um  but apparently in russia it was  something they'd seen  quite frequently especially from people  who'd come from the west to go over  there for treatment